Far Cry primal is a case study in how a
game setting can drive its every layer
from the tone of its story to the
dangers of its world to the brutality of
its combat that setting is the Stone Age
it's 10,000 BC and our protagonist
Takhar is searching for the lost members
of his window tribe they're scattered
across the Oros valley in central europe
a dense wilderness of forests swamps and
frozen caves complete with mammoths and
saber-toothed Tigers as to car you'll
build up a new window village with a
multi Farias cast primitive characters
the identity of each of the game's three
tribes and the political dynamic between
them
sets up conflicts in the natural way but
so too does primals world in fact most
of the game's conflicts arise from
nature
primal still uses the basic open world
framework of a modern Far Cry with a
cascading series of outposts to capture
weapons to unlock and upgrades to craft
but the Stone Age setting is far more
foreboding than those of our Christ past
here vicious animals travel in packs
striking as a collective whole while you
slink through the undergrowth toward
enemy camps a day and night cycle also
adds more tension to the world predators
are more abundant and aggressive in the
darkness even now after dozens of hours
in this valley
I still feel anxiety as the Sun Goes
Down hoping I have enough animal fat to
ignite my club and ward off hulking
carnivores this focus on survival
permeates Far Cry primal in the northern
wastes the cold becomes a factor making
each bonfire a glowing vegan of safety
as you fight to stay warm in primals
lush swampland avoiding danger means
avoiding the water where hidden
predators abound and is a solitary
hunter with simple tools you're also
less equipped to defend yourself than
the protagonists of Far Cry 3 and 4 gone
our handguns and grenade launchers here
you have Spears clubs and slingshot
they not only bring a slow measured pace
to the combat but also add to primals
overall identity and tone and although
there are more ways to die in this Far
Cry than any of its predecessors primal
never feels too difficult there's a fine
balance between tension and fun that
elevates the whole experience the
setting can also be a detriment though
the simple toolset serves the game
themes well but with enough time it
becomes clear just how limited your
tools really are in stealth scenarios I
rely on my silent bow in open combat I
swing my club wildly when hunting elk
and grizzly bears
I use my Spears there are several more
creative tools but by and large I find
myself relying on the same simplistic
options time after time primal reliance
on Stone Age combat to track from the
emergent scenarios that occur elsewhere
but then there's the Beastmaster skill
tree and it's the most impactful change
the Far Cry formula it allows you to
tame creatures recruiting them to hunt
fight and travel with you
Panthers kill enemies without alerting
larger groups wolves can pounce on
distant archers while you close the gap
your owl on the other hand is far more
subtle as it scouts the land ahead
alerting you of possible threats the
Beastmaster abilities are the embodiment
of primal strengths when it uses the
Stone Age setting to elevate the combat
and reinforce the brutal tone of its
world it thrives it fosters a
give-and-take relationship with the
wilderness granting you the means to
survive but also threats to overcome
that focus on primitive times can become
a hindrance at certain points with
limited tools and repetitive combat but
in the end Far Cry primal flushes out
almost every layer of its brutal world